bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono un po vj e ci sono
emozionato perché sto per fare una roba
che non faccio da un po più affaccia a
questo gioco ti permette di interagire
con una coppia di persone sposate tu sei
un loro amico che entra in casa loro e
poi dire loro qualsiasi cosa anche le
cose più brutte e loro ti rispondono ed
è bellissimo solo che devo farlo in
inglese quindi metterò la traduzione
vicino di quello che sto scrivendo già
vi fa ridere che per caricare un gioco
del genere ci mette 60 secondi perché ci
metti 60 secondi per caricare i passaggi
per favore scegli un nome a partiamo
subito ragazzi bisogna scegliere un nome
innanzitutto allora chiamiamoci sergio
che i dari che state per vedere lo giuro
non l'avete sergio yseop and fucking dr
ok fucking dall open fa fucking dall
open ei my friends paolo ma perché
secondo me si è offeso per il paolo non
per il fucking vera bellissimo epico
avevo detto che soggiornerà la
meraviglia fatta gioco fantastico ci
proviamo ragazzi a farci apprezzare da
questi ragazzoni che non è così semplice
oggi fatti degli amici ha in realtà sono
già miei amici prove
sergio open the door please
l'ex carcere scorsi welcome a wright vai
a prendere grace vai a prenderla io
intanto i'm fishing del muro ha preso
del vino the guys i've found some wine
jazz rischia ma pure io e grace drink ok
ok thank you but i was not too much
backhouse prego non regola don't know
what about my pain is no sto scherzando
lo so lo so sono un birbone sono
billboard anni un bacio è così bello
rivederti dammi un bacio grace ma è così
bello avere degli amici allora lo devi
capire dove siete nati giro no no hai
rubato questo zucca ragazzi ho rubato un
oggetto gli inizi sono molto difficili
ma ce la facciamo ve lo assicuro arco
demonio
l'ac knock knock knock salvini rus bat
man entro ciao
ai guanti martini grace bears mi sono
privi thank you i'm gone sit on the sofa
la ai guanti martini [ __ ] nomen i'm
just complimenti simply fatevi vedere
che cosa ci avete in casa piuttosto che
qua non ho mai via si già è vero che
c'era un'altra stanza stupida non avevo
mai capito
yes l'oise looking york steve house
highway hamas che tette comunque a new
york pure fu no che è successo passatemi
il crociato ma edizione tra va tutto
bene pro trevi impegniamo a fare
gentiluomini c'è il telefono che squilla
faccio io prendo brown documentare che
ha in the sexy amante a van hool è
anyway da una scusa gracenote bacio ai
wild joe king i'm not a bad guys di siti
have a nice
look like e minecraft
non è male è un preview suisse ha detto
che degli alberi sarebbero molto bello
yes next time bhuyan house in parco
sempione è niente un suicidio
comunque ragazzi mi spiegate cosa avete
qua why there and is art spider kiss
kiss kiss a glee e sfax giro paura di
lanciarsi ma che posso posso lasciarlo
per terra mi fa schifo come si appoggia
la roba del tipo chi è avverso mi son
drink stato così starò la una palla
reiterati saliti dice le cose tipo
quella roba della verità a questa cagata
caso comunque bel gioco veramente good
grafiche game guys good job tra l'altro
non mi ricordo ragazzi come può finire
perché può anche finire bene sta roba
può anche avere un good ending che non
mi ricordo questo caso ha risvegliato
sari sorry noi buttate fuori non mi
potevo liz harris arrivato in italia ma
come non ti piace di questa l'italia è
bella la toscana
bellissimo
in una parola che cosa mi fa pensare
questa foto oggi i polsi non è così
bassi
fast rassegna ma che cazzo ne so io
robben centered frase sarebbe stata
luigi di majo
non ci vedo se dove sei finita ecco
penso ma come aprendo in forma college
ma chi di chi stai parlando di luigi di
maio stop litiga king size two lovers
rock the fight
come si spiega ma questi stanno all'idea
che cosa vuoi dire per rilassare una
coppia che sta litigando
forza napoli zeitgeist aiea solutions
open the window and make sui side
ok lez get some lance meloni giorgia
meloni
giorgia me mi ha buttato fuori perché se
tu dici la parola meloni questa cosa
risaputa sul passato non era diventato
un meme i tempi se tu dici meloni syngas
non ho mai capito perché ce l'hanno con
giorgia meno quindi adesso proverò a
entrare a dire me lance per vedere la
reazione però teoricamente questa la
mega risaputo ti buttano fuori non l'ho
mai capito perché con questo gioco
incredibile alright ci proviamo ragazzi
proviamoci non so cosa succedeva giorgia
mans
ma perché io non l'ho mai capita sta
cosa ve lo giuro bellissimo bellissimo
basta basta
troppi ricordi però vi sia piaciuto
lasciato un bel mi piace iscrivetevi al
canale e schiacciatela campanellina per
rimandare aggiornatissimi video che
escono come sempre ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo video dai ragazzi
[Musica]